monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur laurent furst monsieur le
premier ministre je ne vais pas vous
parler de berlin mais je vais vous poser
une vraie question concernant le chômage
31 mois de hausse sur 35 6 145 mille
demandeurs d'emploi de plus 1 millions
en catégories à b et c
voilà le bilan de la gauche au pouvoir
un million de chômeurs de plus sans
crise économique majeure et alors que
nos voisins allemands et anglais se
porte mieux
c'est bien l'action de votre
gouvernement qui a étouffé le dynamisme
économique du pays par des lois
démagogique et toxiques pour la vie des
entreprises en termes de croissance
rappelant vos résultats 0 2% en 2012 0 7
en 2013 0,2 en 2014
vous qui aimez fustigé l' héritage de
vos prédécesseurs
laissez moi vous rappeler que la
croissance était de 2 % en 2010 et de
2,1 pour cent en 2011
la comparaison est sans appel
aujourd'hui vous vous réjouissiez d'un
petit mieux au premier trimestre la
france est en fait fuser rossi % de
croissance
un chiffre supérieur pour une fois la
croissance allemande
mais voilà lé ocde vient de publier ses
prévisions pour 2015 1 1 pour la france
1,6 pour l'allemagne 2-4 pour le royaume
uni pour la zone euro la prévision est
de 1,4 bien supérieur à la prévision
française qui restera à la traîne de
l'europe
monsieur le premier ministre les
résultats de la gauche au pouvoir sont
catastrophiques et monsieur montebourg a
raison de dire que vous marchez droit
vers le désastre
monsieur le premier ministre face à
votre waterloo économique
quel espoir peut avoir aujourd'hui le
million de français que vous avez poussé
vers le chômage
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls
monsieur le président monsieur le seul
député nous pouvons continuer nous
l'avons fait les uns et les autres à
nous renvoyer le passé les bilans ce que
je constate c'est que le pays a déjà
vécu longtemps avec une croissance
faible depuis des années avec un chômage
de masse est précisément le gouvernement
s'attaque sous l'autorité du président
république à ce défi considérable mais
puisque vous parlez du passé et
notamment du rapport avec l'allemagne
je veux rappeler qu'au début des années
2000 deux pays l'allemagne et la france
ont demandé un délai supplémentaire à la
commission européenne pour réduire les
déficits
à condition de faire des réformes un
pays a fait les réformes structurelles
qui ont coûté cher d'ailleurs à celui
qui les a fait le chancelier schröder un
autre pays
alors qu'il y avait une majorité de
droite qui gouvernait le pays n'a fait
aucune réforme structurelle est
profondément il n'y a eu pratiquement
aucune réforme structurelle pour
préparer le pays à l'avenir
nous avons connu pendant dix ans à la
fois une désindustrialisation de notre
pays une perte de compétitivité et un
accroissement des inégalités à l'école
et ses grands défis que sont la jeunesse
la formation l'école le soutient
l'industrie l'économie sont au coeur et
du pack de responsabilité de solidarité
avec 40 milliards celle efforts que
consent une nation pour se tenir les
entreprises pour baisser le coût du
travail pour soutenir la croissance et
la compétitivité
nous accompagnons depuis déjà plusieurs
mois ce travail qui avait été engagé par
le gouvernement de jean marc ayrault
avec le cicr et le pacte nous
l'accompagnons avec des mesures pour la
compétitivité est aujourd'hui pour les
pme et les tpe et je veux vous dire
parce que dans ce moment là c'est
important que chacun joue son rôle
partenaires sociaux majorité
gouvernement et opposition
je veux saluer aussi le fait
qu'aujourd'hui les responsables des
entreprises ont dit oui ces mesures vont
dans le bon sens pas pour des raisons
partisanes mais parce que les
entreprises celles qui peuvent embaucher
savent que nous avons pris
mesures qui vont dans le bon sens donc
plutôt qu'être dans la critique
systématique
je vous propose monsieur le député
mesdames et messieurs de l'opposition de
nous rejoindre pour cette priorité à
l'emploi à la compétitivité et à la
croissance et enfin un dernier mot
monsieur le député le sport un rôle très
important grâce aux grands événements
internationaux que nous allons
accueillir ici en france et le rôle du
chef de gouvernement c'est de soutenir
ces grands rendez vous pour la france et
je continuerai à le faire parce que
c'est important pour l'image du pays
pour l'attractivité pour la
compétitivité et pour les emplois pas de
polémique
resto sur l'essentiel merci monsieur